soir sur m6 à son aîné d'un tiers des
volumes pourrait froisser une scène de
théâtre remplace le studio de radio pour
cette soirée spéciale que propose radio
sensations depuis le mois de novembre
deux heures d'antenne sur les six
fréquences de la station objectif
présenter de jeunes talents pour une
émission animée par un autre jeune
talent passionné je fais de la radio
depuis j'ai 11 ans bah je suis passé de
ma chambre à des webradios puis des
radios locales maintenant sur la
sensation que c'est un vrai plaisir de
faire partie de cette aventure être
continué à divulguer plein de culture et
notamment dans les blocs notes culture
de sensations tous les jours au
programme de la musique en live suivez
l'interview pour découvrir les artistes
et leur univers
je vais chanter deux de mes singles qui
se rend dans le pays qui va sortir avant
l'été est également une chanson que je
chante en trio avec des membres de ma
famille le groupe s'appelle en dessous
je chante avec mon petit frère et ma
fille de 17 ans et linz
[Musique]
et un invité spécial l'animateur de
télévision magloire a accompagné
auditeurs et spectateurs tout au long de
la soirée
pourquoi être venu ce soir parce
qu'avais le mot yvelines parce que les
yvelines sont chers à mon coeur parce
que c'est une nouvelle expérience et que
figurez vous que je ne refuse jamais une
nouvelle expérience
la soirée s'est terminée par un militant
dj nantais pourrait écouter l'émission
le podcast est disponible sur le site
internet de la radio
prochain rendez-vous pour sensation en
scène le 17 mars